for the last year what have you been up
to but last year I took off a year from
writing from teaching writing and I've
been focusing on my own writing but and
the other thing I've been doing is
living this list do be in half hundred
things that do be in half what I've
learned is when you relax at least my
three phrases I spent a lot of my life
wanting something that came very slowly
wanting to be the successful writer
wanting to be successful teacher wanting
things and the process of wanting is
actually a very constrained emotion it
limits things right if you think about
the the abundance of the universe and
this huge funnel of amazingness and then
wanting makes it very narrow it actually
makes things come much much slower and
so last year I decided that I would stop
wanting I would just allow whatever to
happen to happen but I was gonna kind of
clear my slate and so I cleared my slate
of teaching and cleared my slate so that
I could just both live and see what
happened like what if I stopped wanting
to be a writer what if I stopped wanting
to be a teacher what would happen right
and so I did this experiment and a
couple things happened on my list of a
hundred things to do be and have those
things just started coming really
quickly so in the last year I've had the
most remarkable year of travel concerts
and crazy things and I've also relaxed
into knowing that there is great timing
and they cut my confidence for both the
ideas that I have and their development
has
offend into this sense of knowing that
I'm on the right path at the right time
and that I don't have to muscle it for
it to occur and in and so it's almost
like I've taken a huge exhale and all of
my muscles have just softened and I am
getting much it's much easier to write
it's much easier to be happy as I write
it's much easier to believe that what I
write is going to land in the perfect
place and and I don't have that tug of
wanting and not getting so from that
place I just have this great sense of
wanting to teach people things that I've
learned and to have people to be able to
give other people the gift of exploding
their writing there's the other thing
about being a teacher sometimes is that
you spend a lot of time nurturing other
people but when you don't when you're
well is not full then it's much harder
to give what they need right and I've
had this year of really filling my well
and experiencing life and getting so
many things on my list of do being have
that now I feel like I can I can give
people so much more energy and so much
more attention and so much more insight
into how to be creative and how to
manifest their dreams and how to
manifest the life that they want because
I feel like I'm I've done that I've done
some great things and I can show you how
to do that too there must have been
quite scary those because I get the
sense that you may I mean everybody in
LA is driven it seems like they wouldn't
stay in this city sometimes probably
they wouldn't be so so set on
accomplishing certain things but it
sounds like that's a very scary thing to
do if you're driven driven and
want things and to just let it go and
and walk away from that for a little bit
how was that uh it is it is I do think I
do think we have to be willing that it's
important to figure out why you want
something and if you're wanting
something because your father told you
you were you were meant to do it or not
meant to do it right you're doing at or
out of a sense of I'm gonna show you
right and it goes back to that idea of
knowing who you are
and appreciating that the people who are
really great writers live and if you're
stuck in a world of struggle you're not
living and you don't remember who you
are because you've defined your life as
struggle and trust me that's not who you
are your life is so much bigger and so
for me it was getting out of this
Hollywood Los Angeles I've got to look
I've got to drive this car and live this
place and look at how my life look a
particular way to be valued and instead
say what if I were just happy what would
that look like
forget being the successful super a list
writer what would happy look like and so
I chased happy and in chasing happy I
feel like I can do anything and that's
just so much more fun than struggling
you're now entering back into writing
it's story Expo 2015 so you're are you
able to take more of like you said this
this sort of like this relaxing this
deep breath because you have kind of
crossed those things off on that list
and and what's that like to kind of come
back
it's almost feels like you're entering
the mainstream again or something I'm
entering the mainstream but I'm also
entering the mainstream with this larger
knowledge of how diverse the marketplace
is I just met with a Sony executive from
Russia who's just sold selling things to
Turkey I'm talking to people who have
who need content on every level and so I
have a really deep appreciation of how
much content is needed in the world how
many stories are needed in the world and
from this place of being kind of full of
my own happy I'm very confident that
both my stories will find a home and the
people that I work with have stories
that will find a home and once you take
out that the sense of struggle and you
begin seeing how expansive this
marketplace is how expansive the need
for content is and how much really the
whole world is calling for you then and
I and I feel like I can share that with
the people that I work with to really
give them a very strong sense that they
can relax because their work is needed
and wanted in the world and and I know
this and I know this because I have I've
relaxed enough to see it there's a book
called I think meditations for women who
do too much Anna Wilson chief
and it's it's about that whole being
driven and and and it's funny because
what boss that I had actually gave it to
me and it was her book oh how do you
relax into that when you maybe start to
see your your haunches getting up when
it's like oh I see that I and I want
that I want that then you're like wait a
minute wait a minute
I'm gonna come back to the place of just
maybe not wanting are there other things
to bring you back well first you have to
know that you're wanting is just the
sign that the universe wants to give it
to you straight up so you can relax you
can want it it's kind of like knowing
that you you you you're wanting
Christmas to come well christmas is
coming you don't have to do anything to
get it right so that wanting is the sign
that it's coming now you may not know
how it's coming and that's where the
hamster wheel comes in because we think
we have to do it all ourselves and
that's why I suggest the list of do be
in half because I'm telling you the list
of do being have generates it and I the
other thing that I do very strongly is
this letter a letter to the universe and
I just came back from Burning Man and
that was my project because four years
ago I wrote a letter to the universe and
I promise you every single thing on that
letter came true and the technique is
basically being able to feel what's
coming without needing to know how it's
coming so if for example you want an
amazing writing career why do you want
that white writing career well I want to
be famous I want to like what's the
experience of your day-to-day life that
feels so good to you being a writer and
if you can get to that if you can say I
if I said okay well I want to be able to
get up in the morning and have my cup of
tea and not have a day
job it's just me and writing and I have
a beautiful desk and what am I looking
at well I have a window with a garden
and I can see what time is it in the
morning oh it's it's 7:00 in the morning
okay so you're starting your day at 7:00
and so if I can get somebody or if I can
if I can get somebody to talk about what
they love about the idea of being a
full-time writer and feel it feel the T
in your hands feel the sense of fingers
on that on the keyboard feel what it
feels like they'll allow the ideas to
come feel at the end of the day how much
you've written feel what it feels like
what do you do do you work until 2:00 do
you work so really feel the day if I can
and feel okay so then what happens so I
want to feel what it feels like to be in
a bookstore and see somebody picking up
my book I want to feel what it feels
like to stand in front of people and
read right and the more you anchor into
the Y the experience the sense of being
in this future life and then begin to
see yourself as realizing that that life
is true it's coming and that's why you
can feel it then you just have to follow
you follow your instincts and it will
come it will come and you'll be amazed
it will come so for that woman who's
who's getting sucked into how do I get
there and do I need to network and maybe
I should go to that meeting I would say
spend more time feeling what your future
life looks like and the impulses that
come to you the ideas that come to you
will lead you to where you want to go we
all the path for everyone is very
different and the more connected
you are to knowing what you want your
life to look like the more will come
there's a very simple simple metaphor in
mountain biking just true in life where
you look is where you go in mountain
biking when you're on a single track if
you look up you go up I don't care how
small that track is you keep looking up
the bike will stay on that road this
wide but if you look down you will go
down so the more you look at I don't
have what I want I don't know how to get
there I don't know what I'm doing I
don't know if I need to talk to that
person the more you'll get that the more
you say I know something's gonna guide
me there I know my ideas are good I know
they're getting better I know my path
will work I'm just going to be patient
for it the more that you'll get that so
look up look up look up and relax it's
it's knowing that when you look up the
whole energy of your body and the
connection to the earth keeps you on a
straight path it's the physical and it's
also how you manifest what you want in
life